let's talk about for this is best
buddies but this is a very much like an
idea we've met before namely Commission
right just by the name just by the name
of Boris right what can you tell about
forces now why would an employer but
give bonuses to their employees out of
the kindness of their heart maybe why
they doing it it's an incentive right
and that's exactly what Commission's are
about do you remember that we're about
trying to incentivize high performance
and so goods don't like Commission
because they reward high performance of
different kinds
yeah question you you're the employer
I'm your boss
why might you choose bonuses rather than
commission what would make this maybe
more advantageous in your particular
context it is okay
number one you might say well you know
it's not gonna even flow with the
seasons right like oh we have a good
time of sales - bad time of sales so
maybe you'd say stability that's a plus
someone give me an all one there's a few
I okay good so you know we're doing in
commission right we kinda just assumed
that everything is about selling stuff
but this kind of lots of jobs where
you're never in the position of selling
something directly you just work for
your company you produce a product when
you do a service and it has nothing you
never get anywhere pressure question oh
these are my sales for the week right
someone give me example what's a job
that has nothing to do that teacher I
don't sell anything it's been saying
like some people have said yeah you know
what we want to reward really great
teachers with some kind of merit pay and
they try and do something like a
commission and they try it - well
student performance like if students do
better then teaching it's paper I'll let
you have a feature about those social
implications of that and why why
teachers rather the world hate ideas
like that you think that wouldn't be
against being paid more but
what a very nuanced politically correct
way of saying it now like I said I think
the basic problem is this is a relative
to seven jobs like if you're an
accountant or your garbage collector or
if there are lots of things we do a cell
phone so therefore they're different
because primarily they have nothing to
do with sales and they are usually there
for an annual percentage of salary
so there are ways that this does connect
to the sales just kind of less directly
so for instance a company might be okay
I'm on the IT team for a company that
does sell stuff right but I'm not I'm
not the person doing the sales but if
I'm doing my job well then someone else
is gonna sell more stuff
so our company would have like a sales
target we want to grow by 10% this year
and if as a company we do that
successfully
it's like will we all get an extra 15%
the end of the year it's doing that same
reward thing but it's a less to protect
kind of like it's it's modest mechana
courses I saw more this maple it's a
bigger picture so that's the way it
bonuses work they tend to attach to
salaries so it's like okay I earned
$20,000 per annum this year on my
part-time job and my my bonus on top of
that would be ten percent or twenty
thousand which is two thousand so my
total income is 22 okay
all right now it's a bit different but
it's similar because of this little bit
in here leafleting we kind of mentioned
this idea before without doing the
exercise never remember what leaf
loadings about it
very good you take you're going you have
four weeks on your leave or whatever it
is not only do you get continually pay
if you actually get it paid more right
now this is kind of weird right it's
sort of if you want to figure out this
way while you're getting them pay the
same amount every week it's like we'd
get paid a little less all the way
through the year and then we did a bit
of a sort of like a fat amount of cash
again or whenever we take it's a way to
solve the problem all and this is kind
of a this is actually like almost
everything in the financial world is
trying to solve this same problem is
it's only the fun of having the right
money at the right time
why do you think people would not like
to actually just get paid more all the
way throughout the year and not have me
live any suggestions why people want the
money sooner they actually wanted a
specific comment on it so
[Music]
okay because if you're awfully you
actually have higher expenses right not
only this the plane ticket or whatever
but accommodation and you're just going
to on holidays you want to spend more
right but that's still even though
that's true that doesn't directly answer
the question of why not just for the
other forty eight weeks just more can't
you say that haha so if I get the money
early on if I do it
hold off my check and just keep working
and paying the same balance right you
never heard
maybe a quintic our city is the fun this
is our cemetery synthesis you get to it
throughout that door over there
sorry what was I Oh correct holidays why
I wouldn't want the money all up and
they don't ever heard the phrase um this
money is burning a hole in my pocket
what does that mean that means yeah it's
like I've got this money and then I see
a big I can buy right and that pool is
very very strong for all of us okay so
this is a way of saying look if I have
it now if I have that money now that's
the wrong time to have this money I've
got to stop myself because I know I know
the self control and having that money
early and you stop and leave until the
right time when I need it
um lots of things in the finance world
just kind of break me out on this
specifically are at solving this problem
but in the reverse way for instance how
many of your parents have a mortgage
yeah okay I am a mortgage right hands
down a mortgage is about solving the
same problem how does it work it's the
same problem as completely backwards any
thoughts
what problems are emotional
so a house costs one like in our area
you're looking at like you want to do it
oh yeah like Hillary yeah like 800,000
900,000 1.1 million 1.1 an insane amount
of money okay
now amazingly yeah over the course of
your life you get decent paying job you
actually earned that amount of money by
the time you'll like you know 55 60 65
you will earn that amount of money and
not just like not just parroted like
including area expenses and you can
actually save that about money
however you kind of want a place to live
before you get to 55 or 60 or 65 in
otherwise you're gonna get the right
money but you're going to get at the
wrong time when you're you know at the
south end of your life okay so therefore
they say mortgages on you're taking with
that money but you're gonna get over
this amount of time and saying look can
I access it now like I'm good for it
I've got a job as you know I've got pay
slips I can prove I'll be able to pay
this amount off can you give it to me
now so I can actually make you sooner
I'm pretty into investment in your house
so financing or being raised is kind of
like time travel it's time travel for
monies it's moving money to the right
spot in time so that you can use it
appropriately
okay like for all of it
all right one last name and someone
mention it leak lighting is also a
percentage right it's a very strange
percentage you should write this down
he's almost always seventeen and a half
percent okay now does that look to you
that'll lead them up
that's a weird number of a psychic when
is a way to read those like he's come
from why would they love each other and
I can tell you right now the basic
backstory but I had any notice like this
but a is that our trade unions people
who represent workers who get paid this
league they say we want more right and
then actual employers and whoever stays
into AFRICOM differences you'll say yes
pick up and eventually they will come to
some kind of compromise and often the
compromise is some reader
at this if you halfway between 15 and 20
percent so when you see that number to
be familiar with it what it means is
you're going to add that similar or not
so for instance let's think about this
five an annual salary of let's say let's
just do a nice round 50 doesn't okay
what's up what am I gonna burn you need
to calculate this what am I gonna earn
per week
169
that's not 61.5 know if that's gonna
work okay yeah it's a bad week
okay so what's gonna happen is generally
speaking for four weeks of the year
those for which you take annual leave
you're gonna get that plus 17 to 5% you
have two ways of doing it I could work
out or what is can you work out for me
what is 17 and a half percent
a hundred and sixty eight point two
seven separately yeah so what I can do
is I can take that and I can just add
none right and then I feel more fun at
four alternatively I could take this
right and I can incorporate the late
learning with the about how supposed to
get paid which is just one hundred
percent so I could take this instead of
multiplied by a 17% I can multiply by a
hundred and seventeen and a half percent
okay can you go ahead and go ahead and
do that just pop it into your calculator
right you can see what that's doing is
it's including this and this kind of
only wonderful and both of them are fine
alright so someone getting about 1,000
1,100 twenty nine point eight one okay
so you can see I would have gotten that
number how I added this to this okay but
I just kind of gone directly there right
just like in previous cases if you're
saying that if you're doing that well
you should say it like that number that
number shouldn't come out of the blue
whichever party go through the question
and you want to clarify it
yes
yeah great question okay so in some ways
not kind of season to it this I'm
hundred seventeen huh actually comes
from two numbers right
it comes from a hundred percent plus
something like I said right so here is
your live learning there's an extra bit
and he is just what you're supposed to
get in anyway
like the full amount that's 100 percent
means something that's empty and
opposite means the full map and the
extra has one big plan
yeah so you all go multiplying by
Perkins